definitivamente este es un hecho más que
evidencia la deriva autoritaria que
tiene este gobierno efectivamente
la pareja presidencial viene conculcando
una serie de derechos políticos básicos
fundamentales para la convivencia
democrática ha encarcelado periodistas
también tiene una legislación que
básicamente es
represiva y persecutoria de el
periodismo y de los periodistas y este
es digamos un
aporte más en la línea de conculcar es
la libertad de expresión en nicaragua y
eso abona a un clima político
autoritario y represivo que impide la
realización de una salida democrática
político democrática en las elecciones
que vienen recuerdo que están a pocos
meses de hacer las elecciones en
noviembre si alberto hablemos
precisamente de esas elecciones
presidenciales ya que usted tocó el tema
en la cárcel están 32 líderes opositores
entre ellos 7 precandidatos
presidenciales tendrá entonces ortega
unos comicios sin competencia que hay
130 y estos 32 son recientes no hay
posibilidad de elección con competencia
las personas que están entre las
personas que están detenidas están las
que tienen mayor posibilidad de
representar una oposición alternativa
frente a la oposición
colaboracionista que es lo que está
quedando en el juego electoral entonces
no hay posibilidad de que hay un proceso
electoral con condiciones mínimas
ahora las tensiones de los precandidatos
opositores a la presidencia de nicaragua
además de todos aquellos que critican al
gobierno ha generado un choque
diplomático con los países que han
levantado la voz ante esta situación
política de nicaragua le importa esto a
daniel ortega a menos de tres meses de
estas elecciones presidenciales
pareciera que no le importa pero lo
cierto es que ahí se plantea la
hipótesis de que estas
primero que estas acciones diplomáticas
equivocadas que están tomando contribuye
a su aislamiento y aunará a su no
reconocimiento después de 7 de noviembre
el reconocimiento de las elecciones y lo
que se supone es que la pareja
presidencial la pareja dictatorial
quiere básicamente utilizar todas estas
medidas como elementos para negociar un
reconocimiento alguna forma de
legitimación después del 7 de noviembre
o sea para la pareja dictatorial el
juego empieza después del 7 de noviembre
y lo que se buscaría negociar liberación
de personas detenidas el levantamiento
de algunas de las restricciones
alivian a miento de medidas represivas a
cambio de suspensión de sanciones y
también algún tipo de reconocimiento que
les permita una cierta normalidad entre
comillas
alberto gracias por su tiempo y por
estar aquí con nosotros en france 24 y
como periodista siento mucho lo que pasa
con respecto a la libertad de prensa en
nicaragua